es gibt Dinge die muss man mit seinen
eigenen Augen gesehen haben um glauben
zu können dass sie tatsächlich existiert
dazu gehören Grand Canyon Naturspektakel
wie die Polarlichter und wenn man
berichten glaubt auch Halong Bay eine
Bucht in Vietnam und genau in dieser
Bucht findet man ein Boot das Luxus
Komfort und ein einzigartiges Erlebnis
verspricht ob es das aber wirklich
halten kann ob es das Geld wert war und
warum dieser Mitarbeiter nicht ganz so
happy über unsere Anwesenheit war
erfahrt ihr in diesem Video ich wünsche
euch viel Spaß mit ich habe einen 5
Sterne Luxuskreuzfahrtschiff getestet
und genau hier startet die Reise mit
einem Speedboot zum großen Boot auf dem
Schlaf das Boot liegt 15 km vor der
gleichnamigen Stadt in Vietnam namens
hallo uns wurde gesagt eine Fahrt in der
Bucht gehört zur Vietnam Reise wie das
Armen in der Kirche des weiß auch jeder
in Vietnam diese Touren werden nämlich
von unheimlich vielen Anbietern
angeboten aber ich wäre nicht ich wenn
ich nicht das Beste vom Besten buchen
würde willkommen auf der Stella of this
[Musik]
mit insgesamt vier Decks und hoffentlich
voller Luxus 32 Mitarbeiter 22 Zimmer
einige wenige mieten ein Pool mit
Jacuzzi und sogar eine hauseigene
Minigolfbahn auf dem Schiff und über die
nächsten drei Tage schlängelt sich das
Boot durch die verborgenen Felsen der
halonküste dem tausend 1500
Quadratkilometer großen unesco-welt
Natur her
wir sind auf dem Boot ein Riesending
hier schlafen wir hier essen wir hier
werden wir Spaß haben hier passiert
alles wir kommen einfach
der Anfang war schon mal sehr
vielversprechend und absolut auf
luxuslevel uns wurde unser ganzes Gepäck
abgenommen automatisch aufs Zimmer
gebracht das war aber erst betreten
nachdem wir unser fünf Gänge Luxus Lunch
zu uns genommen auf dem Schiff
angekommen gibt es als erstes
Mittagessen fünf Gänge im unheimlich
viele Angestellte hier die uns schon
vorbei Boot ausgebunden haben das Boot
ist riesengroß und ich kann es kaum
abwarten das gesamte Schiff mal unter
die Lupe zu nehmen jetzt aber als erstes
essen als Vorspeise eine
meeresfrüchtesuppe begleitet von einem
gemischten grünen Salat super im
Anschluss einen gratinierten Hummer
gegrillten Lachs mit passionsfruchtsoße
und als Nachspeise einen Mango
Cheesecake besser hätte hätten wir nicht
starten können satt und zufrieden wurden
mir nach dem Essen vom Tisch bis zum
Zimmer eskortiert und da gibt es einiges
zu entdecken herzlich willkommen im
Herzstück der gesamten Reise für die
nächsten 24 Stunden unserem Zimmer
tretet ein
[Musik]
im Eingangsbereich haben im Prinzip nur
einen Schrank und einen kleinen coffee
table mit Minibar allem was man braucht
für die Versorgung 30 Quadratmeter
insgesamt auf der linken Seite starten
wir mit der Toilette typisch asiatisch
aber sie heißt uns sogar willkommen also
noch hochtechnisierter als alle anderen
die wir bisher gesehen haben eine
Station weiter die Dusche Boden tief
ziemlich groß mit Regen Dusche und super
gut ausgestattet allgemein muss ich
wirklich sagen das Boot ist ziemlich neu
fühlt sich sehr gut an und finde ich
super schick vor der Dusche haben wir
ein Waschbecken frei stehend im Zimmer
gefällt mir super gut man hat Ausblick
nach draußen in die wunderschöne Natur
und das hier ist dann im Prinzip das
gesamte Zimmer super geräumig riesen
Fenster riesen Fernseher riesen Bett
Kingsize wir haben eine Menge Platz wir
können unsere Sachen alle ablegen wir
haben einen Arbeitsbereich wir haben so
eine Karriere um am Fenster die Zeit und
die Fahrt zu genießen dann eine
Weinflasche geschenkt bekommen der Boden
gefällt mir sehr gut ist alles in so
dunklen holzigen Tönen und dann ein paar
verschiedene Pastelltöne hier noch
schwarz jetzt wo ich gerade sage sind
schon sehr viele Farben es wirkt etwas
zusammen gewürfelt gerade mit der bunten
Tapete dann noch aber insgesamt gefällt
mir das wirklich sehr gut
ist nicht besonders weich und nicht
besonders kämpfte ist sehr hart aber die
Erfahrung haben wir in Vietnam eh schon
gemacht das scheint ziemlich normal zu
sein aus dem Bett hat man Ausblick auf
die Riesen Fensterfront wieder auf die
Natur und auf das absolute Highlight
dieses Zimmers die offene Badewanne
steht mitten im Raum auf noch mal so
nach holzerhöhung auf so einem Podest
und sieht richtig gut aus wir haben
sogar noch so ein paar Dinge dabei wo
wir Sachen abstellen können das bedeutet
eine room service bestellen würden
könnten wir dort drauf alles abstellen
wir könnten essen trinken und dabei
rausschauen kann aber nicht nur
rausschauen sondern auch rausgehen wir
haben nämlich einen riesigen Balkon mit
liege mit Sitzmöglichkeiten wir können
auch an der Seite des Boots noch
weitergehen also der ist wirklich
riesengroß und genau zu sein die Hälfte
der Boden Breite und der hat das Boot ja
gesehen es ist wirklich riesengroß und
hier lässt sich entspannen hier kann man
rumlaufen hier kann man draußen trinken
hier kann man
all das tun was man draußen macht und
das ist hammer
[Musik]
naja und nachdem wir das zum erkundet
haben was dann Zeit schwimmen zu gehen
was nicht jeder so cool fand aber wir
bleiben direkt beim Wasser sieht die
Schwimmwesten an macht euch bereit wir
gehen auf Kajak-Tour kajakur jetzt geht
es für uns in so Höhlen in socapes helle
und dunkle auf dem Kajak es gab auch
eine geführte Tour aber wir wollen
action
[Musik]
also man muss schon sagen das ist echt
cool hier gerade wenn man hinten
rausfährt ich meine schaut euch um es
ist niemand da wir sind komplett alleine
in dieser Bucht und hier ist absolute
Stille also auch wenn das am Anfang echt
krass touristisch gewirkt hat und dass
das auch ist macht das wirklich Laune
und äh ist echt cool also das sollte man
auf jeden Fall mitnehmen wenn man auf so
einem Fuß ist
aber das sollte nicht das einzige
aktivitätsangebot sein was auf dem Boot
angeboten wird von einer Bootstour mit
Locals in die schwimmenden Dörfer über
einen Tai chi-kurs bis hin zum
tintenfischangeln bei Nacht ist so
ziemlich alles dabei was man sich
vorstellen kann Tintenfisch Angeln und
andere Aktivitäten schön und gut aber
was hat das Boot eigentlich noch so zu
tun das Boot ist wirklich riesengroß
insgesamt über vier Stockwerke auf den
so ziemlich alles verteilt ist was man
braucht im ersten Stock allerdings nur
Zimmer oben im zweiten Stock wieder
Zimmer hier befindet sich auch unseres
und ganz vorne eine Minigolfanlage ja
auf diesem Schiff gibt es eine
Minigolfanlage
das hier ist die gesamte Anlage wird
gerade noch vorbereitet für unsere Match
heute später am Abend ich werde hier
ungefähr so stehen
und dann die verschiedenen Kurse alle
mit einem Schlag beenden außerdem haben
wir natürlich einen Fitnessraum ich habe
die etwas falschen Schuhe an aber er ist
da hoch ins dritte Stockwerk hier
befindet sich alles was die Gemeinschaft
braucht also zur Rechten ein Essensraum
der für alle Leute Platz hat und wo es
sehr gutes Essen gibt dazu später aber
noch mal mehr und hierdurch mein
persönliches Highlight an der Bar vorbei
zum Whirlpool das hier ist im Prinzip
das Sonnen Deck auch wenn das Licht
gerade schon etwas dunkel geworden ist
inklusive eines Whirlpools in Übergröße
das ist tatsächlich ein Whirlpool das
Wasser ist piss warm mega geil und man
kann beim Fahren beim stehen die ganze
Zeit 24/7 da rein nach vorne rausschauen
zur Seite rausschauen die Natur genießen
und hat diesen Blick aufs Boot und genau
am anderen Ende des Boots auch auf der 3
wartet noch der teuerste Raum bzw die
teuerste sweet des gesamten Schiffes auf
und das hier ist der Präsident room über
die gesamte Breite des Bootes Zimmer
doppelt so groß wie unseres aber ehrlich
gesagt finde ich gar nicht dass es so
groß wie Präsidenten sweet zwar mit 60
Quadratmetern doppelt so groß wie unsere
schon wirklich große exekte Suite und
erstreckt sich mit dem Balkon über die
gesamte Breite des Bootes sondern
wirklichen Mehrwert hat es aber aus
meinen Augen nicht ein Drittel der
gesamten sweet nimmt dabei das
Badezimmer ein gefühlten noch größeren
Fernseher wir haben einen offenen
Wohnbereich und auf dieser Seite einen
Essbereich damit die President in der
Präsident Suite auch essen können und
nicht mit dem mit dem Pack gemeinsam im
Essensraum sitzen auf dieser Seite ein
großes Bett und im Prinzip was das wenn
ihr nach Vietnam kommen solltet und ihr
überlegt bucht ihr das Zimmer was teuer
oder noch viel teurer ist dann würde ich
euch nicht raten dieses Zimmer zu buchen
weil tatsächlich gefällt mir das kleine
etwas besser und auf dem vierten und
letzten Deck noch mal ein riesiges
Sonnendeck super schlecht besucht sehr
gut für uns da ist wirklich niemand und
der Ketten hier im Prinzip 360° Blick
passt der geilste Platz am gesamten Boot
und jetzt schauen wir mal ob wir beim
Captain im Arbeitszimmer dürfen niemand
da
ist niemand da aber wir können
reinschauen ich meine wir sind ja hier
im Urlaub und was bringt man mal wenn
man im Urlaub ist richtig Cocktails
davon waren drei in unserem Preis mit
inbegriffen und weil wir etwas spät dran
waren gab sie drei alle auf einem
das fünf Sterne luxusboot wäre kein fünf
Sterne luxusboot wenn sie nicht auch
beim Abendessen ordentlich auftischen
würden
zum Mittagessen beim Empfang gab es fünf
Gänge jetzt zum Abendessen gibt es
Buffet draußen wurde fleißig seit über
zwei Stunden gegrillt das ist ja
aufgereiht wir haben ein riesensalat
Buffet sieht super aus man wird die
ganze Zeit beliebt wir haben einen
eigenen Butler so haben wir selber
vorgestellt der quasi die ganze Zeit nur
für unsere Zufriedenheit da ist und
jetzt geht es endlich Abendessen
und als wir uns gerade satt und
zufrieden ins Land der Träume
verabschieden wollten gab es eine kleine
romantische Überraschung
in Felix
Martins and positive vibes
and night sleep tight the temperature
nineteen to twenty grease ja vielen Dank
ich weiß gar nicht was ich sagen soll
die werde ich jetzt essen mit wenig
Abstand
den Wert und würde ich es euch empfehlen
wenn man sowieso in der Gegend ist und
eine Rundreise macht in Vietnam ist auf
jeden Fall ich kann es nur empfehlen
klar das ist die touristenschleuse
schlechthin man ist mit super vielen
Leuten die auch möglichst viel aus den
48 Stunden dieser Rundreise machen
wollen wie man selbst das merkt man
besonders beim Kajak fahren ist einfach
10 20 30 Leute gleichzeitig zum
kaiexport gefahren werden hier viel Spaß
eine Runde kaj fahren ihr kommt wieder
zurück und alles ist super aber so ist
es eben Mitarbeiter haben sich wirklich
perfekt um jeden unserer Wünsche
gekümmert und wer 48 Stunden lang den
Vietnam mal was besonderes machen will
ist mit so Natur auf jeden Fall gut
beraten euch gebe ich dem ganzen dem
Schiff der experience der Aktivitäten
vier von fünf Sternen und alles da
drunter wäre absolut falsch es war ein
krankes Erlebnis in krasse Kulisse auf
einem super verrückten Brot und hat mir
eine Menge Spaß gemacht wenn es euch
auch Spaß gemacht hat dann lasst ein
Video gerne ein Like da vergesst nicht
den Kanal zu abonnieren wir sehen uns in
den nächsten Wochen wieder zu meinem
Service 2 versucht anderen Videos oder
vielleicht zu einer neuen Serie namens
ich habe ein Startup gegründet und das
ist passiert die schneller kommt als ihr
denkt macht's